hello uh this is jason silva and i have
spent the last decade
traveling the planet lecturing at
conferences
government halls
university stages you name it on our
rapidly transforming
exponential world
a world in which disruptive technologies
are every day shaking the status quo
every day
transforming
how we live how we work what we think
whether it's social media massively
changing the nature of how we
communicate or artificial intelligence
making us question what it means to
sentient or
biotechnology increasingly giving us the
power to modify our genes and and
editing our software of our biological
substrate like it feels like things are
going off the rails there are of course
enthusiasts but then there are those
that are rightly concerned things are
changing fast where do we go what do we
do i remember once somebody called this
the age of
insanity because everything is instant
all the time always on but also kind of
insane all at once and so how do we
address the challenges of this age of
insanity how do we move past the covid
pandemic how do we address the grand
challenges of humanity how do we stay
inspired how do we craft new narratives
that move us forward how we become more
agile how do we become more creative how
do we how do we
leverage the plasticity of the human
mind and the resolve of the human spirit
to make this a better world to use these
tools to use these changes to reframe
these problems into opportunities for
self-transformation to up our game and
to seize the day
so if you're out there and you're
looking for somebody to give voice to
the era that we're in please come to me
i'm excited to take this stage
whether it's virtually or in person and
help you turn the page and help you see
the state of things through a new lens
that is optimistic that is inspiring
that will take your breath away we are
increasingly living inside of our own
imagination as we dream so it becomes
and this is the very essence of magic
let's do this i'm jason silva and i hope
we can work together
cheers
[Music]
you